je reprends introduction pour donc vous
expliquez que je vais vous présenter la
réanimation donc principe c'est de
regrouper dans une même unité
d'hospitalisation des patients qui ont
une maladie qui risque de les tuer dans
les minutes ou les heures qui viennent
quel que soit le type de maladie et
quelles que soient les organes touchés
notre relation au temps c'est souvent
celle de la rapidité et lyall hurlant
des fictions quelques minutes ou
quelques heures mais parfois beaucoup
plus et donc je vais vous présenter ce
que dans mon métier l'expérience
l'apprentissage des connaissances et
l'écouté des autres peuvent apporter aux
décisions qu'on doit prendre dans ces
moments parfois critique
douze années d'études à la faculté à
l'hôpital à subir un bourrage de crâne
avec comme mécanisme de défense pour moi
essayer au contraire de retenir
l'essentiel est de mettre de côté ce que
je considère comme étant le superflu
vers la huitième année je m'oriente vers
la réanimation la fin des études se
profile reste la thèse on propose un
sujet sur les très rares complications
cardiaques d'un médicament contre le
paludisme une maladie qui est très rare
en france
je reprends les vieux réflexes de mettre
de côté le superflu jonak mais on laisse
pas le choix
bon je me vous travail je passe ma thèse
ça y est je suis docteur en médecine
spécialisée en réanimation
j'ai 28 ans et je fais une de mes
premières gardes en tant que senior dans
un grand hôpital parisien
vers 4 ou 5 heures du matin après une
très courte nuit
le téléphone sonne arrêt cardiaque en
pédiatrie
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que quand
il n'y a pas de réanimation pédiatrique
sur place comme c'était le cas et qui
est un drame inattendu en pédiatrie ce
qui heureusement est exceptionnel il
reste plus qu'un réanimateurs adultes
misère ça tombe sur moi mais quelle
angoisse mois la pédiatrie moi j'y
connais rien en pédiatrie
bon je me précipite avec une des
infirmières du service et la valise
heures animation la pédiatrie et tout à
côté
j'arrive devant un garçonnet
à la peau d'ébène il doit avoir sept ou
huit ans une perfusion dans le bras et
effectivement il est en arrêt les
infirmières de pédiatrie ont commencé le
massage cardiaque
bah il alla pourquoi ce gamin il arrive
du bénin il a un palu coup de tonnerre
je regarde de plus près la poche de la
perfusion et je vois le nom du
médicament dont j'avais parlé dans ma
thèse je les arrête immédiatement le
reste est simple il est en arrêt
cardiaque depuis quatre ou cinq minutes
je dois faire repartir son coeur j'ai
encore deux ou trois minutes devant moi
avant l'arrivée des dégâts cérébraux
je sais ce que j'ai à faire et j'ai le
temps de le faire injecter les deux
médicaments spécifiquement recommandé
dans ce cas là je les ai dans ma valise
de réanimation lemaitre sous respiration
artificielle
rapidement vous voir partir son coeur
le gamin commence à s'agiter bon signe
son coeur se stabiliser j'organise
tranquillement le transfert en
réanimation pédiatrique dans un autre
hôpital
une semaine plus tard il est déjà de
retour en pays avery je passe juste une
tête par la porte de sa chambre il est
dans son lit en train de lire une bd il
lève le nez et puis me regarde avec un
petit sourire interrogateurs jurançon
sourire je referme la porte j'ai compris
au moment même où je m'occupais de ce
gamin c'était pas mes deux années
d'études qui m'avait permis de le sauver
mais le hasard
le hasard d'un savoir que j'avais voulu
rejeter je me souviens plus de son nom
on sait jamais parlé et pourtant ce
petit béninois m'a communiqué quelque
chose qui a tout changé
il m'a rendu boulimique de connaissance
parce qu'il m'a fait comprendre qu aucun
savoir n'était superflu aucun savoir des
superflu mais parfois ce savoir est bien
difficile à débusquer comme pour henry
il ya trois mois maintenant on nous
appelle d'un autre établissement pour
nous demander de nous en occuper henry
il a 75 ans il a jamais vraiment été
malade jusque là mais là il vient
d'avoir une chimiothérapie pour un
cancer des ganglions pas très agressif
et dont il a de bonnes chances de guérir
mais au lieu de ça
son état s'aggrave son foie lâche et
puis les reins et puis le cerveau les
cancérologues
comprennent pas quand ils arrivent c'est
l'urgence immédiate pour essayer de le
faire survivre le temps de comprendre ce
qui se passe on lui met des perfusions
plein doute tuyaux en branches à des
machines compliqué ça c'est la phase la
plus critique la plus facile et la plus
télégénique de ce métier mais c'est pas
ça qui va sauver henry si on n'arrive
pas à comprendre quelle est la maladie
qui est à l'origine de toutes ces
défaillances d'organes et ça c'est la
partie analytique de ce métier la moins
visible la plus complexe et certainement
la plus intéressante qui est henry dans
quelles conditions habite il est ce qu
il a des animaux à la maison est ce
qu'il est parti à l'étranger en voyage
est-ce que quelles sont ses antécédents
médicaux et très précisément qu'est ce
qui s'est passé récemment ont fait en
urgence des prises de sang des scanners
des échographies des fibroscopie on
fouille son dossier médical
bref on mène une enquête policière la
seule chose dont on est sûr c'est que la
chimiothérapie qu'il a reçus de ne pas
la maladie qui l'a et en trouve pas on
cherche son état continue à s'aggraver
on cherche les heures parce qu'on
cherche
nous n'avons plus beaucoup de temps ça
fait vingt-quatre heures qu'il est là
maintenant et on trouve toujours pas on
est forcément passé à côté de quelque
chose en reprend tout à zéro et on
trouve perdu au milieu des centaines
d'informations que contient son dossier
on voit qu'elle a reçues quinze jours
plus tôt un médicament assez banal pour
prévenir certains effets indésirables de
la chimiothérapie
une petite sonnette se met retentir dans
la tête ça nous dit quelque chose
en tout cas on tient une piste et on va
pas la lâcher
oui c'est bien ça et c'est très rare
deux ou trois cas par an en france en
réanimation semblable à celui d'henri ce
qui lui arrive c'est bien liés à ce
médicament qui peut dans des
circonstances très particulières
réactiver un virus qu'on a quasiment
tous bien caché au fond de nos cellules
et déclenché une maladies virales et
inflammatoires très grave
bon maintenant on sait à quoi s'en tenir
on connaît le traitement a donné le foie
et puis le rhin et puis le cerveau se
remettent à fonctionner henry il est
sorti un mois plus tard du service il
avait bien
ce sont pas les balles chine et les
tuyaux qui ont permis à henry de guérir
mais bien la recherche acharnée
et puis la découverte de l'éguille dans
la botte de foin avant d'en faire le
diagnostic ne connaissions cas c'est
vaguement ce type de maladie mais
personne n'a la connaissance universelle
de son domaine de compétence il faut
l'admettre
et surtout il faut pas s'en satisfaire
le temps en réanimation ne s'écoule pas
de la même façon pour les soignants et
pour les proches
on donne des nouvelles aux proches dans
la chambre bien sûr mais aussi et
surtout au cours de ce qu'on appelle des
conférences familial dans une salle de
réunion
assis autour d'une table la question
posée est toujours la même est-ce qu'il
va s'en sortir
et la réponse est quasiment toujours la
même écoute et on peut vous dire ce qui
s'est passé on peut vous dire ce qui se
passe maintenant il est ce qu'on a
l'intention de faire mais on peut pas
prévoir comment les choses vont évoluer
l'incertitude c'est la règle est en fête
plusieurs études ont montré que le taux
de satisfaction des familles à l'issue
de ces conférences familiale n'est pas
proportionnelle à la masse des
informations qu'ils reçoivent
mais autant de paroles qu'on leur laisse
pour s'exprimer il faut donc donner
toutes les informations répondre aux
questions et peut ensuite se taire
laisser s'écouler le temps ça donne
parfois des blancs de 15 secondes
secondes parfois plus c'est dans ces
circonstances là aussi c'est très longue
et puis au bout du style au bout du
silence ils reprennent la parole
toujours
et alors il parle de la personne
hospitalisée bien sûr mais surtout ils
parlent d'eux mêmes de leur douleur de
leur peur de leurs nuits sans sommeil de
leurs angoisses de leur épuisement
physique et morale et il faut leur
laisser le temps nécessaire à
l'expression de cette douleur parce que
notre europe de soignants se limite pas
à la seule personne hospitalisée
l' écoute des autres l'écoutent des
proches
ça fait partie du soin et ça demande du
temps à la différence des proches
les soignants ne cherche pas deviner le
futur mais bien sûr au bout de quelques
jours
on se fait une idée on se dit que la
balance va pencher du bon ou du mauvais
côté je me souviens de cet adolescent il
ya une douzaine d'années
pour tout dire j'étais mal à l'aise
quand je rentrais dans sa chambre parce
qu'il rentrait il ressemblait comme deux
gouttes d'eau à l'un de mes fils il
avait le même âge pierre il a 16 ans et
une infection grave du cerveau on
appelle ça une méningite bactérienne
il est donc comme à à cause de sa
maladie ce qui va en sortir un jour de
ce coma on n'en sait rien bien sûr sa
mère est dévastée à chaque fois qu'on
entre dans la chambre son regard se
tourne vers nous et nous posent des
questions mettent auquel on peut pas
répondre un jour 2 jours 3 jours il est
toujours dans le coma mais à ce moment
là on l'examiné on voit des petits
signes imperceptible aux parents qui
nous font penser qu'il va peut-être
sortir de ce coma mais on n'en est pas
sûr que dire aux parents écoutez il ya
du mieux peut-être mais en fait on n'en
sait rien impossible au cinquième jour
de cette attente infernale comme tous
les jours je réexamine le gamin est là
ma conviction est faite il va se
réveiller mais j'ai pas de preuve
en me retournant j'affronte le regard de
sa mère et je craque
écoutez je pense que ça va aller il va
se réveiller et me regarde et regarde
son fils incrédules et lui reprend la
main et moi je tremble intérieurement à
l'idée de me tromper
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait en fait je pense
pas qu'ils aient de bonnes ou de
mauvaises réponses
mon expérience me disaient de me taire
me disais qu'il fallait surtout pas
prendre le risque de me tromper et de
lui donner de faux espoirs mais ce
jour-là ce regard m'a fait comprendre
qu'il fallait que je sorte du confort de
mon silence de mon rôle de médecin
prudent et sûr de lui
deux jours plus tard pierre est réveillé
on lui enlève la respiration
artificielle on installe au fauteuil à
travers la baie vitrée de sa chambre je
le vois qui boit son premier chocolat et
sa mère le dévore des yeux
au bout d'une semaine d'un temps qui a
dû lui sembler infini comme mon petit
béninois comme comme henry comme pierre
certains patients s'imprime dans nos
mémoires les cas rare un complexe ou
émotionnellement fort et puis le temps
passe et leurs souvenirs s'estompent peu
à peu mais parfois arrivent ce que
j'appellerais le temps des moissons
michel
c'est un solide gaillard michel un bar à
qui il ya un an et demi maintenant ils
arrivent mourant dans le service le
diagnostic de l'origine de sa maladie
est facile il a une infection pulmonaire
mais il est arrivé trop tard il a dans
un état si grave qu'on pense ma qui va
mourir on sait qu'il va mourir comme on
dit l'expérience ça trompe hors bons
sans illusion on donne tout ce qu'on
peut et puis après tout il est très
jeune il a mon âge
bon on se bat à notre grand étonnement
il passe la première nuit et puis il
serait grave
et puis et puis s'améliore et puis
serait aggrave le yoyo infernale on est
dans sa chambre en permanence et
finalement il s'en sort il finit par
rentrer chez lui après deux mois de
combats
michel hilaire passer nous voir il ya
quelques semaines il avait bien il avait
retrouvé ses muscles 1
il allait bientôt partir dans le sud
avec son épouse voir ses petits enfants
et surtout surtout il était retourné à
la pêche
sa passion toujours nous avions eu tort
en étant sûrs à son admission qu il
allait mourir
nous avions basés notre jugement sur
notre expérience pourquoi est-ce que
nous avons négligé la logique et la
statistique évidemment parce que la
probabilité de réussir on avait
absolument aucune importance il pouvait
s'en sortir
ce serait sans séquelles et ça a été le
cas comme tant d'autres michel nous a
montré que notre expérience nous avez
trompés
voila voila ce métier dont les temps
sont loin de se limiter à la phase
initiale de la réanimation ou c est
celle où on voit à la télévision le beau
dr ross et les jolies l'infirmière
s'agiter autour d'un patient bien sûr
c'est un métier qui est plein
d'adrénaline et qui peut paraît-il chez
certains donner prématurément quelques
cernes et deux ou trois cheveux blancs
un métier qui est plein de technologie
complexe et passionnante et le plus
enrichissant pour moi c'est pas tant la
satisfaction béate de rendre la vie à un
patient qui risque de la perdre pour ça
le temps s'est bien chargé de me faire
ressentir le poids de chacun de mes
échecs dans le plus enrichissant pour
nous c'est que ce métier nous montre
qu'il faut se méfier comme de la peste
de l'expérience qui n'est que ce que le
passé nous a appris et non pas ce que
l'avenir nous apprendra que s'endormir
sur son expérience et fermé son esprit
c'est refuser de progresser et au final
c'est faire du mauvais soins ce métier
nous rappelle au contraire chaque jour
là maxime socratique qui est que notre
premier savoir doit d'abord être celui
de notre propre ignorance et qu'il faut
donc s'acharner a sans cesse augmenté
l'étendue de nos connaissances qui est
la clé de tout et finalement son intérêt
véritable c'est sans doute ce que avec
le temps et si on leur tend l'oreille
les patients et leurs familles nous
apprennent sur nous mêmes
je remercie
[Applaudissements]